from New York Post 10 middle schoolers
were arrested for allegedly assaulting a
Coney Island classmate in a brutal
caught on video bus Beatdown the victim
who one fellow later one fellow student
later callously declared deserved it and
should have
died could be heard shaking in pain as a
pack of kids collectively reigned
punches on him in the January 26th
incident uh according to footage shared
with the post and posted on social media
the boy can be seen trying to protect
his head from the Relentless fists while
he's uh passed down the aisle by his
attackers on an MTA shuttle bus Which
brings kids to Mark Twain is239 for the
gifted and
talented uh brings them from there to
the Stillwell Avenue subway station the
beating continues for several minutes
moving from the back of the cran bus to
the front as the boy is punched slapped
kicked and even hit with a
sneaker uh in all so it's 10 10 kids
were assaulting this one
kid and these are kids apparently from a
gifted and talented School because this
is what passes for gifted and talented
these
days you know I would prefer if they
just got rid of the gifted and talented
programs in schools than lower the
standard to the point where you know
people like this get into it you might
as well just get rid of it I can
remember gifted and talented programs
when I went to school when I was a kid
they had gifted and talented and um I
remember them from the outside I
remember looking in on them I was never
invited uh they never labeled me gifted
and talented and for good reason there's
a very specific kind of kid that would
that would qualify and these were the
kids who were very academically rigorous
and responsible kind of nerdy
disciplined um hardworking you know all
the things that I that I was not and uh
and these kids certainly aren't and yet
they've made it into the gifted and
talented program and since we're going
down memory lane here here's something
else and every time I see one of these
videos I think about this and if you're
my age or older you probably have the
same thought something else I don't
remember as a kid is um I don't remember
fights quote unquote like this you know
um and we're not even going to show you
the video because it's you can go find
it if you want but you've seen enough
videos like this you you know what it is
10 kids like stomping the hell out of
one kid we've seen a million of these
fights now I don't remember that you
know a gang of kids stomping the hell
out of one other kid kicking him in the
head you know as we so often see in
these videos if the kid falls down he
starts getting kicked in the head that
sort of thing I don't remember that
um I I I and and you know I I went to a
very shall we say as they say now
diverse school all through my public
school career it was they're very
diverse schools I wasn't going to prep
schools for trust fund babies um and uh
and there were fights all the time I'm
only aware of maybe that I can remember
maybe two examples in 13 years of public
school where a gang of kids beat the
hell out of one other
kid maybe two examples The Stomping on
the head thing that again is so common
now never saw that never saw it never
heard of
it most of the time it's because a fight
was a fight right and and it could be
brutal sometimes but there was at least
some sense of Honor in it it was usually
one-on-one and um you get into a fight
you go until someone breaks it up which
most of the time is How It Ends or if
there's no one around to break it up
then you go until someone is on the
ground and they're clearly defeated when
you're running a business time is money
that's why I'm so excited to introduce
you to ramp if you're a finance
professional looking for a better way to
maximize productivity and cut wasteful
spending then ramp could be for you ramp
is a corporate card and spend management
software designed to help you save time
and put money back into your pocket with
ramp you can issue cards to every
employee with limits and restrictions
you can also stop wasting time at the
end of every month by automating your
expense reporting ramps accounting
software automatically collects receipts
and categorizes your expenses in real
time so you don't have to you'll never
have to chase down a receipt again and
your employees will no longer spend
hours submitting expense reports the
time you save each month on employee
expenses will allow you to close your
books eight times faster ramp is so easy
to use get started in less than 15
minutes whether you have five employees
or 5,000 get $250 when you join ramp
just go to ramp.com Walsh spelled rm.com
Walsh again that's ramp.com Walsh cards
issued by Sutton Bank and Celtic Bank
members fbic terms and conditions apply
but now there's no honor or dignity and
the way that these kids just brutalize
each other it's a very unmanly cowardly
even sort of a feminite way of fighting
and
um and I think the difference is that
historically when two men or two boys
squared off to fight whether it was like
at the playground a playground fight or
it was a duel in the 1800s historically
the point it was less to harm the other
person even if you did end up harming
them them in the case of a duel you
might kill them but it was less that was
not really the point the point was to
prove your own courage and toughness and
and masculinity to everybody else um
that's what the fight was about and you
wanted to win not simply because you
wanted to hurt the other person but
because you wanted to prove yourself and
that's why you know that's why why a lot
of times used fights what happen in
school because for one thing you're
doing it for the sake of everybody
watching you want people to see because
you want to win and you want to be the
tough guy and also you know someone's
going to break it up at least they used
to break these fights up now they just
let the kids go until someone's dead I
guess but at the time like they break it
up and so and you knew that you knew
that someone was going to break it up so
it was and so it was really it was more
of like a
performance um and you might say that
that's that's wrong you know it's it's
we shouldn't encourage boys to behave
that way um okay well now we don't
encourage it uh you know we say that
boys shouldn't worry about proving their
toughness and and and certainly using
violence to do that we don't want want
that well this is what we get
instead we still get the violence in
fact we get more of it but now the point
of the violence is actually just to
inflict as much harm on the other person
as you possibly
can just for the sake of
it um if you jump some other kid and
it's five onone and you're stomping on
his head while he's on the ground you
obviously have not proven your toughness
like you haven't proven anything you
know you've only proven that you're a
cowardly sucker punching little frankly
is what you've proven but you have
inflicted maximum harm on the other
person which is the point now that's the
point that's that's the goal is just to
let me harm and you heard one as they
quoted one of the kids he should be dead
like that's the way they look at it
let's just kill him you stomp on a kid
when he's on the ground you that's
attempted murder you might kill him
that's what you're trying to do why are
you even trying to do it I mean most of
the time if you were to PLL these kids
or talk to them afterwards like what
what did that other kid do that was so
wrong why were you they wouldn't even be
able to explain it they're not even like
mad it's it's just inflicting maximum
harm on another
person for the fun of it just for the
sake of
it um and that's what's become so common
and it's uh it's it's not good I put it
that way hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there